congress is currently considering the
most radical piece of legislation
in our nation's history conservatives
say
that the equality act would obliterate
the distinction in our politics between
men and women
liberals are saying we're it's crazy
we're overreacting there's no way it's
just fear-mongering so
senator john kennedy put the question to
the head of the largest
lgbt lobby in the country the human
rights campaign which is pushing this
legislation
he wants to know simple question how
many sexes are there
mr david let me ask you a question how
many
how many sexes do you think there are
how many sexes
how there's a difference between sex and
gender identity if that's what you're
getting no i'm
asking biological sexes how many do you
think there are
well i would defer to the medical
practitioners but i think there's been
studies showing that if you're talking
about sex
sex is defined by many different
characteristics and cool and chromosomes
are there more than
are there are there more than two
you could make that argument that they
might be making that
senator i can't ignore the fact that
they're individuals who are intersex
and so i'm just trying it's not
running out of time are there more than
two sexes
in your opinion it's not limited to two
okay
that's all i've got mr chairman that's
all i've got that's all we got
because if we can't answer that question
as a country
we can't answer anything i'm michael
knowless the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from tim mcculte
this actually usually i pick comments
that just sort of amuse me this one
though i thought was pretty insightful
tim referring to this uh this shooting
in tennessee where
a woman a black woman pulls a gun on a
cop and then he
shoots her and the mother of the woman
blames the cop for
letting her shoot him tim mcculty
writes they're claiming that the officer
put himself and the perp in a position
where she would not only commit more
crime but do violence upon him which
makes everything that happened his fault
this really sounds like blaming a rape
on what the female was wearing yeah it's
exactly analogous to that probably the
most
racist part of of this racialist
ideology here
is that the left seems
only to ascribe agency to white men
according to the left's racial ideology
only white men are people you know with
intellect
and will who can reason and then act
upon that will
every other group of people on earth are
passive objects that things merely
happen
too but they can't do anything so even
when this woman in tennessee
shoots a cop pulls a gun and shoots a
cop it can't be her fault
because she is merely reacting to
whatever stimuli come into
come into her mind very vicious stuff
really dehumanizing stuff
but that that is uh what what lies at
the basis of a lot of that
you know you if you hear some
uh sort of crazy answer from the left
on uh sex on
race on whatever if you hear some crazy
ideology you say
there is no way that this is going to
advance in our country this is too far
well you can place your bets that it's
certainly not going to be too far and if
you want to place bets head on over to
my bookie that's right my bookie
absolutely terrific
site to go check out march is here and
madness has officially begun it is time
for you to
shoot your shot and score big on the
non-stop action with my bookie
select the winners from 63 tournament
games in the my bookie bracket contest
for a chance
at 10 000 in cash prizes
it's only a dollar to enter doesn't
matter whether you're filling out
multiple brackets
betting the national championship winner
or simply looking for player and game
props my bookie has you covered
college ball nba and nhl no matter the
sport no matter the minute my bookie
puts the action in your hands with
in-game live betting
with choice from thousands of lines and
odds you can turn any game day
into payday bet anything anytime
anywhere with my bookie you know
among the sorts of recreations that i
like to do responsibly
i always like making games a little bit
interesting and my bookie great way to
do it
sign up today at mybookie.ag and use
promo code knowles know w-l-e-s to
secure a deposit bonus up to one
thousand dollars that is promo code
knowles k-w-l-e-s
to claim your first deposit bonus i want
to get back to what
senator kennedy said there he he asked
the head of the
hrc one of the most dishonest lobbies in
the country an
absolutely awful awful lobby that
pushes cultural radicalism i'm not sure
they even believe this stuff anymore i
think they just
had to keep raising money because they
won the the fight to redefine marriage
so they didn't know what to do so then
they took on the transgender thing
and who knows if they figure that one
out they're going to take on some other
some other issue
but kennedy asks this guy how many
sexes are there and the guy tries to do
this deflection where he says
well you know there's actually a
distinction between sex and gender
which is true only in as much as gender
refers to grammar
what the left does though is they say
gender it's a term that refers to
people's sexuality
but it's different than sex and they
can't really ever explain how it's
different than sex
and they we point out that they're just
using
two different words to say two
contradictory things about
the same actual object but the left says
no they're totally different things so
kennedy pushes the issue
the reason that that kennedy clip
matters is he's showing you that this
whole idea that there's a difference
between sex and gender is just bs
that the left doesn't even believe it
themselves because he says no i didn't
ask about gender i'm asking about sex
how many sexes are there biological
sexes
the guy can't answer the guy can't
answer because all this
post-modern claptrap about you know the
metaphysical gender and the physical sex
and well there's a difference between
biology
they don't even believe that they just
want to obliterate
the sexual distinction in man because
that distinction is fundamental to our
nature and if you can transform that if
you can redefine that
you can redefine anything and then there
is no
there is no limit to the possibilities
of progress
lots of confusion going on these days
not just from the head of the human
rights campaign
not just from the left-wing lobbyists
also from our president joe biden
joe biden said on the campaign trail
that he was going to have a much more
lenient
immigration policy creates a lot of
incentives for more people to flood into
the country
more people flood into the country now
we have an unprecedented crisis on our
southern border
joe biden actually believe it or not was
called out for this
only very mildly on abc they said you
know you
you told people to come here so isn't
this kind of your fault
he doesn't really remember so there's
some back of the first tv
put together just a little back and
forth what he's saying now what he said
then
the idea that joe biden said come
they're there
seeking asylum first time ever we've
told people they can't come to america
that ends the cage is closed the idea
that joe biden said come
we immediately surge to the border all
those people are seeking asylum
they deserve to be heard that's who we
are where a nation says if you want to
flee
and you're fleeing oppression you should
come the idea that joe biden said come
and those who come seeking asylum we
should immediately have the capacity to
absorb
them keep them safe until they can be
heard
do you have to say quite clearly don't
come
yes i can say quite clearly don't come
first time ever
we've told people they can't come to
america don't leave
your town or city or community
now maybe this is just because joe biden
is losing it
that things he said just a few months
ago for this to be the first time ever
we say don't come you have to come
please serge come
i've never said surge i never said come
maybe this is just cause he's
getting a little forgetful in his old
age but i don't think it's that i don't
think this is the sort of thing
that you can chalk up to biden's obvious
cognitive decline
i think that joe biden would have done
this sort of thing in his prime
because what you have to remember about
joe biden it is the defining feature of
his political career
joe biden is nothing
he's everything and nothing he doesn't
have
views of his own i don't think i think
he wakes up in the morning
licks his finger put puts his finger in
the air and figures out which way the
wind is blowing
and if the wind is blowing in the
opposite direction than it was yesterday
he will contradict with a straight face
he will contradict
everything that he said the day before
he lies
effortlessly i don't think this is
because joe biden necessarily
hates the truth i think he is totally
indifferent to the truth
i think he is a pure cynic who
who has been lying from the very
beginning of his prominent political
career
it's why he had to drop out of the race
in 1988 because these weren't just
little white lies
this this wasn't just exaggerating by
crowd sizes
for all the talk of trump's lies really
was just hyperbole in the way that new
yorkers talk that's not what joe biden
was doing he was telling
very specific ornate lies about his
academic record
about his political record he was then
plagiarizing speeches
he's told lies about very crucial
aspects of his personal life
that's just what the guy does so if the
wind blows in the other direction
tomorrow and they say yeah we
you know public opinion shows people
really want to surge at the border
he'll go on tv completely straight faced
and he'll say i've been telling people
to come i've never told them not to come
i've never told them to stay in their
country it's not who we are
joe biden is catching a lot of flack
for what's going on down there at the
border one
issue is that while we heard all about
the kids in cages under trump
actually joe biden is putting more kids
in worse cages cages that he and barack
obama actually built wasn't even trump
who built the cages and
there there is this question of ripping
children from their mothers right joe
biden says we are not
not doing that sort of a thing listen to
the way he muddles up the issue what do
you do with an unaccompanied child that
comes to the border do you repeat what
trump did
do you repeat what trump did take them
from their mothers to move them away
hold them in cells etc
we're not doing that what do you do to
the unaccompanied children who come to
the border do you rip them away from
their mothers
gonna pause it there did you catch the
problem catch the flaw in that argument
these are there are two separate
arguments here there are the
unaccompanied minors
who are being pushed across the border
and then there are
people who are showing up at the border
with kids but really no way of knowing
whether is it they are they their kids
are these adults coyotes are these
adults just random people who are put
together by the
smugglers that's why there is a vetting
process that's why biden's doing the
vetting process that's why trump did it
and that's why biden's not getting a ton
of flack for doing it that's why trump
got a ton of flack for doing it
but it's the same process but you don't
rip
unaccompanied kids away from their
mothers because they're not there with
their mothers what what do you do
in both of these situations we heard
from jen saki yesterday
who was asked by liberal reporters hey
how come
you're doing all the stuff trump did but
just much much worse
and gensake gave the honest answer which
is
there's not a lot of options a question
about the situation on the border
it's now been three weeks since i think
in this room you were first asked about
uh getting us some some press access why
have you still not seen any images
inside these facilities
we remain committed to doing that and i
think uh these facilities are overseen
hhs of course overseeing
overseas the shelters uh the dhs
oversees
the border patrol facilities and uh we
want to
work with them to ensure we can do it
respecting the privacy
and obviously the health protocols
required by covid but even given coveted
protocols and obviously privacy concerns
you know
even you all haven't released any images
that you obviously
could redact if you wanted to again we
remain committed to
sharing with all of you uh data on the
number of kids crossing
the border the steps we're taking the
work we're doing to open up facilities
uh
our own bar we're setting for ourselves
and improving
the and expediting the timeline and uh
the uh the treatment of of these
children and we remain committed to
transparency i don't have an update for
you on the timeline for
access but it's certainly something we
support you're obviously not committed
to transparency because you're not
letting the reporters go in and actually
see the cages
so two days ago we heard this on the
show yesterday
jen saki says look there's not a lot of
options please stop bugging me about
this
then yesterday you get the reporters
saying we were told you're going to be
transparent
why are you not letting reporters in to
see these facilities
why are the customs and border patrol
officials
telling us that they've been told that
they're not allowed to say anything to
the reporters
why are you being so opaque about all
this and what does jensaki say she says
with a perfectly straight face
well you know we're really committed to
transparency and we're more than happy
to give you talking points we're more
than happy to give you what we want you
to report
but no we're not going to let you into
the facilities because the facilities
are looking worse
than they ever have before you know
after i go out with the boys some nights
i'll be looking worse than i ever have
before the next day
one reason i love liquid iv one serving
of liquid iv provides the same hydration
as drinking two to three bottles of
water alone
what makes liquid iv so effective
cellular transport technology ctt
the optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water and nutrients
into the bloodstream
it is the perfect balance to help you
hydrate more quickly and effectively
than water alone
you know last night i went out had a
couple coca-colas with
drew clavin and you know if you're
feeling a little
like you could be refreshed in the
morning liquid iv a great way to go good
people i think use it when they exercise
the rest of us you know after a night
out it's a nice thing to have
grab your strawberry liquid iv or there
are other great flavors in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code michael mich
ael at checkout that's 25 off anything
you
order when you use promo code michael
mich ael
liquid iv.com get better hydration today
at liquid liquidity.com promo code
michael you will thank me
later joe biden cannot articulate a
political vision
because joe biden follows the prevailing
winds
this is part of why they're floundering
here on the border issue
it's not even just the incompetence of
implementing the policies it's because
biden can't articulate the policies when
he's talking to a democrat audience he
says yeah
we want open borders we don't we want to
let people come in surge the border
please come come come
but when he's talking to more moderate
audiences he says
look we uh we're sending a lot of people
back we're sending more people back
than trump did and we believe in law and
order and
yada yada so there's no there's a total
conflict here
trump knock him if you will say he
didn't build enough of the wall
say he didn't deport enough foreign
nationals sure
but he did always articulate that vision
and people would come to him and say
there's a crisis at the border far less
of one than we see right now under biden
what what did trump say and what did
trump's advisors say they said look
we're a nation of laws and we need
borders
don't come here we're going to throw you
out it's going to be very bad if you
come here stop it
we don't want you to enter our country
illegally
that is a clear vision and it is why
you did see at least for certain periods
of the trump administration those
immigration numbers tick down
joe biden giving all these mixed
messages
creating a far greater problem because
if you stand in the middle of the road
you are going to get hit by a truck now
some politicians
can articulate a political vision one
good example of this
ron desantis governor of florida who's
done a very good job on kovid
he clearly i think has his sights set on
the white house
so he keeps i got to give the guy credit
he keeps
making all the right moves he's moved on
just from the kovid stuff which is what
had really been
putting him in the spotlight now he's
moving on to a cultural issue
critical race theory radical leftist
anti-american indoctrination
in our schools ron de santa says no more
florida civics curriculum will
incorporate foundational concepts
with the best materials and it will
expressly
exclude unsanctioned narratives
like critical race theory and other
unsubstantiated theories
[Applause]
let me be clear there's no room uh in
our classrooms
for things like critical race theory
teaching kids
to hate their country and to hate each
other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
so we will invest in actual solid true
curriculum
and we will be a leader in the
development in in implementation
of a world-class civics education i
i love this uh this press conference i
love this announcement i love the
initiative
what he's saying here explicitly is not
just hey we're going to make sure kids
keep reading shakespeare
or hey you know let's we're going to let
everybody do whatever they want to do
and schools can pick whatever they want
to do he's going further than that
he's saying we will not permit this
trash in our schools it is being
excluded it should be cast into the
outer darkness
where there is wailing and gnashing of
teeth and that's the right answer
this is a point i make for many pages
with lots of historical examples and
lots of arguments for it in my upcoming
book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
these abstract
a historical arguments that are merely
formal about
free speech versus censorship or
something like that
have very little to do with the actual
cultural battles at hand cancel culture
political
correctness this massive indoctrination
campaign in our schools
the real question is standards what are
we teaching
when we teach one thing we're living in
a finite world it means we necessarily
can't teach the other
thing if we're teaching the 1619 project
for 10 weeks of our semester then we are
not teaching the 1776 commission okay
and so you've got to make choices mitch
daniels who is now the president of
purdue
is formerly the indiana governor and
there was some talk that he would run
for president 2012.
mitch daniels got gotten a lot of
trouble for this there was an email that
came out from when he was governor that
said
i don't want howard zinn the leftist
historical revisionist blemishes i don't
want howard zinn
in our schools i don't want that
anti-excrepal
anti-historical trash i believe was the
phrase
from the email get it out exclude it
conservatives need
to become much more comfortable not just
making sort of abstract formal arguments
about how
you know we've got to hear out
everybody's ideas and sure we should
have the 1619 project in schools
but it should also in the free
marketplace of ideas have the
counterpoint or whatever
no we we need to recognize that
education in particular is coercive and
it is limited
and we need to teach certain things it
has a purpose
and the purpose of the radicals and
critical race theory in the 1619 project
is to destroy our country so we should
have a civics education
that builds up our country and desantis
is making that claim
now a lot of people are saying oh my god
santa's he's going to be the nominee in
2024.
hold up guys you know it's there's a
long way
between here and 2024. i love what he's
doing i think that's great stuff
uh we should be encouraging this from
all of our politicians there is a long
road to go before 2024
uh politicians need to prove themselves
you know especially if they haven't
been in the national spotlight for a
long time but definitely
really good stuff from governor desantis
speaking of critical race theory
speaking of people who were clearly
poorly educated
don lemon don lemon on cnn
uh theologian cardinal
future pope don lemon uh was
discussing religion recently right he
was discussing the vatican's
decision to continue to hold the
christian view of marriage that they've
held for 2000 years
so don lemon was spouting off he said
look god would never judge anybody
never mind that in the nicene creed we
acknowledge that
christ will come to judge the living and
the dead and his kingdom will have no
end no forget about that forget all the
references to judgment in the bible
no no judgment no vatican they've got to
get on board with
the don lemonite christianity don lemon
is now making both a theological and a
historical claim
that jesus is black and we also have to
start
uh being realistic about god and the
bible and if you are
a person of faith in this country and we
know america is built on faith and
religious freedom
then we have to i think a good way of
starting
is to present the true identity of jesus
and that is as a black or a brown person
rather than someone who looks like a
white hippie from
sweden or norway and i think we should
start with a true depiction of what
jesus looked like and put that in your
home
either a black jesus or brown jesus
because we knew jesus looked more like a
muslim or someone who was dark
rather than someone who was blonde uh a
blonde looking carpenter
and then when your children ask you who
is this this is jesus
jesus was middle eastern bethlehem was
not in stock
in sweden and so jesus does not look
like the
um popular depiction that we have in our
churches
uh and in our homes and that we see all
over the media and i think
that is a good place to start
jesus is not a black guy first of all
when you begin with
jesus was as as you're pontificating to
christians about their religion you've
made a crucial error
because christ was crucified and then he
rose again from the dead and ascended
into heaven and is seated at the right
hand of god the father almighty
jesus is a jew his mother
was mary his father is god
the father the first person of the
blessed trinity in christ is the second
person of the blessed trinity
and the holy spirit the bond of love
between the father and the son is the
third person of the blessed trinity so
real is that love that it
he is his own person
just for don lemon to come and say look
we just have to deal with the historical
facts okay jesus
was black that's historically ridiculous
it's just not true
well jesus wasn't swedish yet no one
says he was swedish
do you have you looked at any uh western
art any western depictions of christ
they vary some i guess he's lighter
skinned than others but
he looks like a jew
i don't know he doesn't look black you
don't look swedish he doesn't look
norwegian or whatever he
looks like a jewish guy which is what he
is
there are also some clues as to what
christ looked like in his bodily form
as he was incarnate on earth and uh we
can see this in the shroud of turin we
can see this in other places
but the the historical claim is
silly and we can dismiss it the worst
part of it is
that he's ignoring the central
fact of christ the the most important
fact
he knows uh just about as much about
depictions of jesus as he does about
higher christology
the error here is trying to center
christ's identity in race
there is neither jew nor greek nor slave
nor free but all are one in christ jesus
christ who comes as a jew to this
specific chosen people
has his message spread by the apostles
to all of the gentiles to all of the
world
all coming into one in human human
dignity human solidarity
salvation open to all mankind and this
shmuck don lemon focuses on
kooky theories about the race of the
redeemer of the world who could possibly
care less
about the race of the redeemer of the
world the fact is the redemption
don lemon missing the point a lot of
people have missed the point
that it's a big hassle to go into brick
and mortar auto parts stores and have to
you know talk to people and answer
questions about car parts you don't have
to do that anymore you can go
to rockauto.com rockauto.com is
so much easier than walking into a store
and someone demanding all those quick
answers to things about your car
that you don't know about maybe you know
about it i don't know about it
they go in the back they don't have the
part they order it online they charge
you twice as much
do not do that it's really important i
think right now to have all the parts
you need for your car especially
these days we had some rough weather
last night over here in nashville
you don't want to get caught you don't
want to get stranded so
when you go get those auto parts go to a
family business rockauto.com
reliably low prices they don't change
their prices with all sorts of gimmicks
you know you just you can always count
on it
same prices for pros as they have for
do-it-yourselfers
do not chuck money out the window and
spend twice
as much for the same parts go to
rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car
or truck then tell them that i car
expert michael knowles write knowles in
there how did you hear about us box
let them know that i sent you
rockauto.com head on over there right
now
also make sure you listen to ben's show
today
ben will be discussing when the left
does care about
anti-asian hate and when the left does
not care about anti-asian hate
very specific circumstances here so make
sure you go check that out
you know there's a buzz in the air over
here at the daily wire studios
candace owens filmed the first episode
of her new show yesterday
it is all anyone in the office can talk
about this morning
you are going to love it candace
premieres tomorrow it will be unlike any
other daily wire show you've seen before
if you would like a sneak peek of her
new show join candace owens and the rest
of the daily wire gang tonight
for a special edition of backstage do
not forget candace premieres tomorrow
it will be exclusive to daily wire
members
so i don't want to spell this out too
much here if you're not a member you
don't get to watch it
so head on over become a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe
use code canvas for 25 off dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
there are many worthy causes on earth
there's so much suffering so much pain
we are called to charity
and so we take our finite resources and
we give them to the people we feel
are most in need like prince harry and
meghan markle for instance right
this according to a a gofundme
there is a gofundme set up to help
harry and megan pay off their 14
million dollar mortgage in montecito
california
that's the that's the bad news for our
culture the good news is
the gofundme has folded in less than a
week i guess this is a harry and megan
super fan
i didn't know those existed but there is
one out there at least
the the 14 million dollar gofundme
raised a total of uh
110 dollars which is
about 110 dollars too much in my mind
but then it folded up this actually ties
in with this racialist
ideology that you hear from people like
don lemon and
really you hear it from everybody
critical race theory in the classroom
and the corporate boardrooms and
everywhere else
the racialist ideology has so taken hold
in this country
that even meghan markle can claim to be
a victim
even a hot famous
rich princess
can claim to be a victim if she is even
one-quarter black my sicilian mother was
much darker than meghan markle doesn't
matter according to the
racialist ideology du jour meghan markle
can claim
to be a victim and being a victim
carries social currency it doesn't carry
real currency on gofundme apparently but
a lot of other places
it does president trump was asked
he was speaking to maria bartoromo and
he was asked about
his views on meghan markle and the mexic
and her
prospects because megan is it has been
said and reported by sources close to
her that megan is looking to run for
president
in 2024 president trump gives his hot
take
what was your take on megan markle uh
now saying she
meeting with democrat operatives she may
want to run for president
well i hope that happens because if that
happened then i'd be
i think i'd have an even stronger
feeling toward running
i'm not a fan of hers i think that what
she
talks about the royal family and the
queen i happen to think i know the queen
as you know i've met with the queen and
i think the queen is a tremendous person
and i am not a fan of megan
i'm not a fan of megan i also love trump
they're like you know my friend the
queen
yeah my friend the queen she's really
great i love her
but yes if if megan were to run that
would be
all the more reason for president trump
to jump in as well it hasn't been
working this
this kind of grievance politics has not
been working
for harry and megan why not
there are plenty of other rich
successful famous
people who play into this race hustling
sort of fashionable ideology
and it does sometimes work for them why
not
harry and megan it might just be a
bridge too far
to have literal royalty
claiming grievance it might
it might just be a bridge too far forget
trump for a second
even michelle obama who
is no conservative michelle obama
who has said that the first time in her
adult life
that she was proud of her country was
when it elected her husband
michelle obama who has embraced sort of
some of the rhetoric of racial grievance
she's been
she's been somewhat curtailed in that
but she's she's dipped her toe in those
waters
even she says come on megan give me a
break i wonder when you watched meghan
markle
speak out what went through your mind
public service
it's a bright sharp hot spotlight
and most people don't understand it nor
should they the thing that i always keep
in mind is that
none of this is about us in public
service
it's about the people that we serve but
what about when she talked about the
fact that she experienced racism
i mean i feel like that was
heartbreaking to hear that she felt like
she
was in her own family you know her own
family
thought differently of her race isn't a
new construct
in this world for people of color so it
wasn't a complete surprise to hear her
her feelings and to have them
articulated i think
the thing that i hope for and the thing
i think about is that
this first and foremost is a family and
i pray for forgiveness and healing for
them
uh so that they can use this as a
teachable moment for us all
pretty good take from michelle obama i
never thought i would say this on this
show but
pretty good it's not a perfect take you
can see what i mean when i say
she dips her toes in those racial
grievance waters where she's a
says do you think meghan markle had
seriously suffered racism she goes well
racism it's nothing new
it's like yeah but right it's nothing
new but do you think meghan markle
suffered from hatred for i don't think
so charles walked down the aisle to
marry his son
i don't think so right they would have
dealt with the marriage beforehand if
it were some big issue of a race or
something uh that that's obviously not
what happened but broadly she's saying
look it's a family let's just like pray
for them and not
you know this is ridiculous and then on
the megan question
she is really a brutal line she says
this is not supposed to be about us
now it's ironic coming from michelle
obama because barack obama
is probably the most narcissistic
politician
of our lifetimes and i'm counting donald
trump in that
a healthy ego is a professional
hazard of politics might even be a
requirement if you're running for
president
but obama really took that to the next
level where he said
the earth would heal the sea levels
would cease to rise
we are the ones we've been waiting for
we're the hope right
that sort of stuff was was pretty silly
but at least you know hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pace to virtue at least
michelle obama is saying yes
it's really not supposed to be about
us and megan needs to stop making this
all about her
but this idea of racial grievance is is
really taking hold it's not just in the
universities
not just in high schools not just in
politics
it's taking hold maybe most especially
in corporate america
deloitte major consulting firm
deloitte i mean one of the biggest
consulting firms in the world they told
their employees
that unintentional microaggressions are
considered a punishable offense
punishable offense now this was during a
mandatory anti-racism training
the u.s employees at deloitte were
introduced to the company's new
anti-racist culture i guess previously
deloitte had a racist sculpture
but now the new one is the anti-racist
culture
employees were told that they are
expected to help cultivate anti-racist
culture when working with personnel and
clients and promote equity
one example how do you have an
anti-racist culture well one example is
quote asking your black male colleague
to join the flag football or basketball
team
if if you're working with a black guy
and then you know you your friends at
the company have a
sports team if you invite the black guy
to participate
with your white team that's
racist if you exclude the black guy from
your
from your sports team that's anti-racist
um not not sure i'm following the logic
now i suppose what they are getting at
here is that black people tend to be
better athletes and
integrate many sports than white people
but maybe that's even racist now to say
is it racist if you're complimenting
someone if you say like for instance
asians have higher test scores
they're probably better at school i
guess that's racist
that's not by my definition that's a
compliment but i'd like to be told that
italians are better at
eating pasta carbonara so i don't know
we're exactly better at but uh you know
i guess italians are better at exploring
that's something right christopher
columbus
verizono murrago vespucci the map guy
that's pretty good we run recklessly
into danger and expl that's
i would like to be told that as a
stereotype
but if you
invite a black person onto your team
whether it's because you think he's a
good athlete
or whether it's because you're friends
with him no longer permitted you can be
fired for that
at deloitte employees are racially
biased according to deloitte if they are
not in favor of affirmative action
programs
and there we go now we're getting into
the heart of it
these silly examples about the sports
teams they're just kind of to distract
from
what this is really about which is
prohibiting
conservative forget even conservative
just non-radical
political points of view in the
workplace
plenty of black people oppose
affirmative action
clarence thomas opposes affirmative
action
he wrote about affirmative action and
that the pitfalls and the evils of
affirmative action
beautifully in his memoir my
grandfather's son
plenty of people oppose these policies
but now if clarence thomas were to
espouse a view on affirmative action
he would be called a racist an
anti-black racist
if clarence thomas were working at
deloitte he could be fired for that
you're going to see this more and more
it's going to begin with affirmative
action but it's going to expand into
other policies soon it's going to be
that if you think that men shouldn't use
the women's bathroom at the office
that is bigoted it's they'll i guess it
won't be
racist they'll call it some other ism
and you could be fired for that
and what this is all about is enforcing
a new set of standards
on the culture and you're going to have
these squish
naive maybe worse than naive
pseudo-conservatives in part and they're
going to say
well you know deloitte's a private
company and so if they want to destroy
our culture they could totally do it
that's wonderful that's what our
founders would have wanted
and you're going to have actual
conservatives saying what are you
talking about
we you the same people who are now
defending
deloitte or amazon or any of these big
giant corporations
that are destroying our culture you are
the very people who said that we need to
go and take back the universities and
take back hollywood and politics is
downstream of culture
yeah so okay let's fight in the culture
well no they're a private company we've
got to do whatever
whatever they want to do that's totally
fine no
how about no how about we stop making
excuses for why we can't
push back against the left's wicked
designs
to upend our culture and destroy our
country
and how about we assert a good positive
political vision and then actually have
the guts to defend it wouldn't that be
nice
why don't we do that either we will do
that
or we will cease to have anything to
conserve
this is by the way this is this is not
even not a i have no shame in making
this plug because i really want people
to read this book because it makes this
exact point
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is available for pre-order
until amazon figures out what it's about
and then they're going to take it off
the website
this is why the candace owens
cardi b battle fascinates people
i think i don't say this just because
candace is my friend
and we've got this great new show with
candace and everyone should watch that
candace puts these sorts of issues in a
uniquely
stark light particularly on the race
stuff
particularly on the sex stuff why
because the country right now is
obsessed with race and sex
and they say that all black people need
to think a certain way and if if you
don't vote for joe biden you ain't black
and all women need to vote a certain way
and candace
just by existing contradicts those
theories
but it's further than that candace also
has guts and she's willing to say it and
she's not going to back down and she's
going to
say whatever she wants to say and good
luck if you try to
shut her up candace and cardi b
according to the left's
shallow material sexual racial view of
politics
there's no difference between candace
and cardi b right
according to the left you know black
people they're all the same and
women they're all the same and so
there's no difference but there's quite
a difference isn't there
these these two women could not possibly
be
more different from one another
which way will we go
not just which way will black people go
which way will women go
which way will our country go because
these two people
who look very similar have very similar
physical attributes
think desire value
pursue very different things
our views our identity
our politics is
not defined exclusively or primarily
by what we look like there is more to it
than that when don lemon
focuses on christ's skin color
not only is it stupid not only is it
ignorant
but it's totally missing the point which
way will we go
the candice carty feud is great because
you see oh there really are options we
really can pick a path do you want to go
down the whap path
or do you want to go down the
freedom american tradition
preserve our way of life path which one
you you got to make the choice
in our culture racism is the unique sin
it's the worst thing you can call
somebody right now is call somebody
racist
sure that's it's very bad it's an
offense against human dignity we all
acknowledge that
there are other sins and because
the left has so succeeded at eroding our
perception of the traditional objective
moral order
we we can't make sense of any evil in
the world other than through this lens
of white supremacy
or patriarchy racism broadly
but there are other sins tragic shooting
happened a couple of days ago at an
atlanta area massage parlor
uh this this guy shows up the white guy
shows up and kills eight people in a
massage parlor tuesday night
he's 21 years old he's confessed to the
crimes
i think six of the
uh people were these asian masseuses
the the attacks began around 5 p.m
at the young's asian massage parlor in a
strip mall
in a rural area at near ackworth about
30 miles north of
atlanta two people died at the scene
three were transported to a hospital
where two of them also died i think more
deaths came in even after that though
i'll have to check you got the point
very very terrible thing
we are now being told that this is
because of white supremacy
because there's anti-asian hate crime
and this is part of white supremacy
if you look at the statistics not even
just from this year but for many many
years and decades even
of the demographics that commit
crimes against asian people it ain't
white supremacy let's put it that way
i'm not even particularly interested
ben will talk more about anti-asian hate
and that sort of thing on his show today
but the idea that there is an epidemic
of white people
running around killing asian people
because of their skin
is not supported by the evidence not by
a long shot
but this is what everyone jumped to they
said this because it confirms
this fictional narrative that the
cultures put forth that this guy was
motivated by
racial hatred and the cops who are given
the they're investigating this
giving giving a press briefing on it
they're saying you know it
it doesn't seem like race is the issue
here it seems like there's another sin
at play we did interview him last night
he is currently
in our facility at the cherokee county
adult detention center uh we were able
to interview him
with the atlanta police department and
the fbi um he made
indicate indicators that
he has uh some some issues uh
potentially
uh sexual addiction and um uh
may have frequented some of these places
in the past
and um but as the chief indicated is
still early on we still have a lot of
things to process and what this rate
should be motivated
as the chief indicated it's still early
but the indicators right now
are it may not be
uh it may be targets of opportunity uh
again
we're we believe that he frequented
these places in the past
and um may have been lashing out uh
and part of that is is in your media
packet as well but the working theory is
a sexual addiction issue rather than a
a racial profile uh during our
interviews
uh we asked that specific question and
uh and
that did not appear to be uh the motive
did not appear to be the motive now this
this cop is in real hot water publicly
because he was giving an explanation of
what happened he said it was a race was
it race and he said no i think it was
that that he's got these
addiction issues and obviously these
mental issues and he had a
particularly bad day and that set him
off and he went off and committed this
crime
and what trended on twitter they said he
had a bad day he had a bad day this is
covering up for white supremacy and they
just went back to the same
the same narrative so what what are they
what do they want the cop to do they
want do they want the cop to be some
emotional guy this evil terrible
monster we're gonna kill him we're gonna
no that would be
wrong for him to do that it's up to the
prosecutor to do that but for the cops
who are investigating this gathering the
facts
they've got to be neutral and of course
if the situation were reversed
in any of the particulars you would hear
all sorts of excuses
yes no uh you know we covered that story
yesterday
in the tennessean about a woman who
pulled a gun on a cop and
shot him and the article was very
sympathetic to her and
more or less blamed the cop for allowing
her to shoot him write all sorts of
excuses
but i'm not interested in excuses for
any of these i'm not interested in jacob
blake's excuses
i'm not interested in this kid's excuses
i'm not interested in any any of those
sorts of things
i am however interested in
the motivations because the motivations
will tell us
quite a bit about our culture about the
crime and about perhaps how to prevent
the crime in the future
this massage parlor was i think
pretty clearly not just a massage parlor
there were three of these asian massage
parlors on the same block just about
they're all right in the same
neighborhood
something tells me there was a little
bit more than massages going on here
this is a problem that goes on
throughout the united states
and everyone knows that it's happening
and this guy apparently was frequenting
these houses of ill repute
and had this sexual addiction and this
impelled him to this horrible crime if
you
blame this on racism which is the cop
says it does not appear to be
you're not going to figure anything out
you're not going to do any any good to
help prevent these sorts of things in
the future you're not going to deal with
the root problem you're just going to
propel a leftist fantasy that that
is really divorced from reality but what
if there are more sins than sins of
racial hatred what if racial hatred
isn't even
like one of the most prominent sins in
the country
do we think that really there's this
sort of ubiquitous racial hatred do we
think that the ku klux klan is really
prominent the country
no but licentiousness sure is
that's not an excuse for someone to
commit a crime but it is an explanation
perhaps
it is a problem perhaps it is something
that we might want to deal with while
we're dealing with racial problems while
we're dealing with drug problems right
the
the opioid epidemic that's an addiction
issue
and it leads to certain crimes and
you've got to punish the crimes but you
also want to deal with the
addiction issue maybe
these this sexual insanity that's taken
over our country
where we now have the mainstreaming of
drag queen story hour
adult men transvestites twerking for
toddlers where you have 11 year old drag
kids
having dollar bills thrown at him at
bars
because he's dancing for grown men maybe
that's a problem too
maybe our antipathy toward our own
country that's spreading through
critical race theory
to use one example but through other
other means
maybe that's a problem too maybe
division
and distrust of our countrymen and the
suppression of perfectly
mainstream and conservative political
views like we're seeing it deloitte
maybe that's a problem too maybe
we we can't see what's going right on
under our noses
because we've been so blinded by
ideology
maybe we can't even say how many
biological sexes there are
like john kennedy showed us while he was
grilling that lobbyist
if you can't answer those simple
questions if you're unwilling to take a
look at even the most basic facts in
front of you
how are you supposed to fix any problems
i'm michael moses the michael knoll show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there